and I don't care that people who tell me
think that because I'm a Japanese girl I
should dance
flamenco this always has to be
proud
because we don't have the habit of
keeping feelings
for myself dancing is not
expressing and degrading my thoughts they
use with my body
[Music  ]
I'm silent with a tasting
but now about him too
[Music]
I never imagined
what
[Music]
barceló working
payró
at the beginning when I started dancing
flamenco I always had doubts because
I'm Japanese
and I wanted to change my appearance I
wanted to change more I wanted to be Spanish
I fought a lot
work is I thought it was impossible to
work some promising girls in Spain
but I struggled a lot when
my program disappeared to use the stage I
really like that the public
enjoy my dance
[Music]
life was very bland when I saw it on
television
I think whoever was
yes
in this  world for seen father
[Music]
what happened I
wanted to do with that day in
forgotten hong kong point
[Music
] art  it is emotion and emotions are
universal
[Music]
I really like to convey my
feelings and feelings of salt from
your heart and heart here the pair of giving
their best so for me it is very important to
add top part hand by mouth
my passion is for me  most important of
my compassion
lament space my passion
[Music]